Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Agar.io.
Now, I haven't played it in a while
and there's been a lot of changes made to the game.
And actually Agar.io mods doesn't work anymore
so I can't exactly do that.
So now, I'm just gonna be playing on my own and in a party.
I sent a tweet out to everybody
who wanted to join up on my party,
and there may be some people that are going to join me.
I, I'm not entirely sure.
But, as it stands right now I'm just gonna do my best,
standing on my own with 'Kim Kardashian' following me from the behind,
and 'Hello Mark' over there!
Oh, god, no!
Who is that?
Oh, I'm gonna get boxed in!
Oh, they all think that they're me!
But I'm not me- They're not me!
I'm me!
I'm the only me!
Aww, people are giving themselves to the other Markimoo.
You're a faker!
You're a clone faker!
You're not the real me...
I'M the real me!
I'm the only me here.
So, I-I did tell people that I was gonna be playing this
but I didn't tell them what my name was,
so it is kind of a secret.
So they have to kinda guess.
And if that Markimoo causes problems for THIS Markimoo,
then I'M going to be very upset
and I'm going to be frankly not happy with any of it!
It's going to be 'MMM'
and I'm going to be 'HMM'
and there's going to be a lot of 'hmms' and 'mmms' all over the place.
[Markiplier's eating noises]
Mmm, so delicious!
Please feed the Markimoo!
You've got one too many 'O's in your name.
BLORF
[Markiplier's eating noises]
Hmm, yes, good. Yes.
Don't give THAT Markimoo! He's bigger than me!
That's a bunch of baloney!
He's not the real me! I'M the real me!
ME! And only ME is ME!
You can't be me! I'M me!
[annoyed humming]
'Notapenis666'.
Yeah, it's-it's wonderful. Not a penis.
'Mark I feed u'. Hey, feed me!
Feed me! FEED ME!
FEED ME!
Give me! Ahh! Give it to me!
Whooooahohoho!
There we go.
Man, 'LUV MARKIPLIER' got a big start on this one.
'Team Chica'?
Haha, other Markimoo! Who's the bigger one now?
You get sucked into me!
Yeahhh! *laughs*
Yeeeheheheheheyeeess...
Aw, no!
Aw man, he's getting away.
Team Chica! Get eaten!
Get eat!
Get ate!
Feed Markimoo!
Yes, they're starting to learn!
They're starting to learn who their true lord is!
Their overlord...
MARKIMOO.
Oh no, it's getting crazy in here!
There's too many people!
Oh god!
Oh god no!
Ah, leave the Markimoo alone!
Leave me alone!
I'm just gonna go back here,
into the, the birthing corners,
and then hope for the best once I reassemble,
and then everything's gonna be lovely.
'NOTICEMEMARKPAI'
I'm right here. Your senpai is here!
'Markimooisbae'!
Give! Give to me!
Give! I need your help!
No! Oh god! 'Kimboraffe'!
Everything's so scary.
Oh good, finally I'm reforming!
Give me your power!
Give me all of your power!
Ohhh this is the best.
There's so many people!
'Mark My Moo'
I'm not gonna 'mark' your 'moo'!
That sounds like dirty~
Uh-oh.
Something happened here.
HURBLURF
HURBLEFPTH
Okay.
'Mark My Moo'. Give me-
Uoh-oh, that ain't good.
That ain't good! Ah god!
AH GOD!
AHHH NO!
Ahhhh... shit!
I reached level 4, though.
They added a lot of like, ah,
little things like this, so there's a lot of um...
*uneasy chuckle* There's a lot of microtransactions now
and that's unfortunate,
but you know.
I guess they wanted to make more money, and...
I can't really fault them for that.
So, anyway.
Oh wait, no. Hang on.
I'm gonna throw myself into Jumbo.
I'm gonna see-
- 'Mark Fist Me'. I will not, sir!
Or ma'am!
Either way, the answer is still no.
'DA REAL MARKIMOO'.
'MARKIMO'.
'DA REAL MARKIMO'. *laughs*
Let's see if this works.
'DA REAL MARKIMO'.
*Laughs* Is anyone gonna believe me?
I think the answer is actually 'no', 'cause-
Whoah, this server is getting nuts!
Oh man.
No! I'm real!
'DARKIPLIER'! Don't do it!
I'm the REAL one! I'm the REAL Dark!
Dark, don't do it!
Oh god!
No one's gonna believe me because there's a misspelling in it.
'Markimo'? They're like
'Markimo? That guy's stupid!'
'There's no way!'
Give me love! Give me mass!
I'm never gonna get started 'cause there's so many people here!
Oh god, no!
I'm the real Markimo! Believe me!
Believe me! Oh shit.
Oh, shit.
Ahh, shitskies.
Ahh, shit.
Ahh, 'Danny Sexbang'.
Fuck!
'SALOMONEITOR'!
I can't believe I pronounced that right.
I'm so scared, I'm just tiny.
I'm tiny!
I'm almost too big for these things.
Come on, give the Markimoo.
Give the Markimoo.
Give!
Oh god, I'm too big for this.
[strange grunting]
No, 'VANESSA'! Don't do it!
Don't! Don't!
'VANESSA'! Don't! No!
You've- you've got so much to live for!
No!
'Grammar Nazi' don't you dare.
'Grammar Nazi' don't you dare!
Oh good, I'm still small enough for this.
Uugh.
Uuuuuugh 'BOOBYSWEAT'!
'BOOTYSWEAT' sorry, I thought it was 'BOOBYSWEAT'.
'Markimoo Lover'. Come here!
Come here! Come here! Come here!
It's me! Trust me, it's me!
It's the real me!
It's the real me! You can believe me!
Oh god!
Oh god, this is bad.
Slowin' down, laggin' laggin' laggin'
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
'BubbleButt'. I'm gonna get killed by 'BubbleButt Tim!'
AHH!
Ahh... *laughs*
'BubbleButt Tim'.
'BubbleButt Tim'...
Ah, man...
Once more into the br-
Oh f-
Ohh, 'SEPTIPLIER AWAY' got eaten up
just as it should be!
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh no, 'FARTIPLIER' ain't gonna do so good!
Fartiplier ain't gonna succeed!
Fartiplier ain't gonna make it very FARRRR
It's me! It's Fartiplier!
Trust Fartiplier! Fartiplier!
Ah! YouTube Red's coming after me!
[Moans of a man expecting an anticlimatic death]
Sick moves, bruh.
Thanks, me.
Give me your body, 'Septiplier'.
Give it to me.
Give me your body!
No? Okay.
[Markiplier mating sounds]
Getting squeezed between 'Krisscendo' and-
Oh god, this is very scary!
AHH! 'Mini MARKKI'! NOO!
That was supposed to be me!
Oh, man.
'MarkiDong', 'Fist Me Mark'-
Again, I-I-I-I say no to that.
I don't, I don't want to.
I reeeally don't want to.
Oh, I hope-
Ooh my, it's just a sandwich!
It's just a sandwich!
Oh, god. It's just a sandwich!
AH! OH GOD
Noo, Emily!
Why have you done this?
No! I will not fist you! Stop asking me to!
I don't appreciate these-
AHH!
Oh god!
AHHH!
Aha! Too big to eat!
Fuck you.
Oh no, 'Darkiplier', don't do it!
'Darkiplier' no!
No! I'm too beautiful to die!
We seem to have escaped most of the people
but 'Darkiplier' is chasing me down and it's not cool.
Whoa! Whoa whoa!
'Darkiplier' don't wanna mess with this now!
Haha!
Who's the Darkiplier now?
Ohohohoho
Heheeh.
Ohhhh, no.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
[Uh-oh-ing intensifies]
[Intense Uh-ohs]
Uh-oh!
UH-OH!
It's me!
Mary! It's me! It's me! Give me!
Oh god. That ain't good.
'Mini Boy Mark'. Come on, trust me! It's the real me!
It's the real me!
It IS the real me!
It has to be! Who else would it be?
'Markimoo_Lover'...
'Markimoo_Lover' can you-
Can you, can you assist me, 'Markimoo_Lover'?
'Mini Boy Mark' I don't wanna do this to you
but I really, really actually do wanna do this to you.
YEEH
There we go.
Now we're getting somewhere-
Uh-oh. We're just a bigger target.
We're just a bigger target!
Oh god!
'Markiplier?????'
Oh, god. No!
No, 'Loopy'! Don't do it!
Ehhhh no don't do it!
AHHH!
AHHHHH!
Awww, man!
I was actually doing good there!
Now, I can't, I can't put out my name
on the Internet, because then people would just be like:
'Oh! I'm gonna type that name in and then I'll be good!'
I should be, I should-
I should get the Leprechaun,
just because that'll be something identifiable
and it's something that not everyone would be able to get.
But I don't have enough coins...
Oh, but then I'll have to spend money?
[Disgusted noise]
Alright.
No one do this!
No one do what I'm about to do!
I'm doing this for the sake of doing this!
And also, I should-
[COUGHCOUGH]
Okay, so I did something incredibly stupid
and I actually bought coins.
Don't do that, everybody.
But NOW, I...
I am a leprechaun.
Aha! Can you see my clever ruse?
Now no one will be able to suspect!
No one! Will be able to withstand my Irish charms!
I can't believe that this skin was available.
No, come on! Trust me!
I'm me!
'ASS' almost blasted halfway across the map.
'DARKIFART'.
No, not 'DARKIFART'!
No! Don't get Jack!
Ah god!
Eugh!
Save Jack! Everyone loves Jack!
Whapshhh! Top of the mornin' to ya-
Oh god, why?
Let's try this again!
Euuugh!
[Not-Irish noises]
Man, that-that guy is big!
Oh fuck! I didn't even-
Oh my god!
Alright.
TOP OF THE MORNIN' TO YA LADDIES!
OH GOD!
[something about fucky ducky?]
Oh god!
[???]
-Gotta get over here!
Ooh lordy dordy day!
'Assclap' don't get me!
Oh 'KittyDerpz'!
[Terrible Irish sounds]
- This is how Irish talk-
[... I don't think so.]
[Yet more 'Irish' noises]
[He's not even trying anymore, folks.]
[Gibberish]- Oh god, there is no room anywhere here.
The big ones are gonna get so big,
that they're just gonna start popping no matter what th-
AH!
Oh god, 'KittyDerpz' won out of that one.
Don't kill Jack! Don't kill Jack!
Don't kill Jack!
Ahhhh!
Jack, your Irishness is useless! It's not helping!
It's not helping at all!
AHH!
It's not helping!
Nothing's helping!
The goggles! They do nothing!
The Irish whiskey! It does nothing!
AHHH!
There's so many people that are pretending to be me
that they're getting to the top of the leaderboard.
This is bullshit!
This is a bunch of bull!
This is not how this was 'supposed to go!
This was supposed to be MY moment of victory!
Oh, something big is happening over there.
'fuckin mark' I know, right?
What an asshole, ruining the server and all.
'chica the dog'!
Are you gonna help me? Help Jack!
Help Jack!
'NOT SO GRUMP'? Get in my belly!
Yaaaaah!
SaHUUU-Yes! I did it!
I got someone!
Get 'Warfstache'- Oh shit.
That ain't good.
This is wooor-
Dududunuh!
Oh man.
Oh god, there's just so many big ones!
Oh, god!
Oh man, the leaderboard is changing every single second of every single day!
Eugh!
That is not what I would call good.
This is the OPPOSITE of good.
Ohh 'LITTLE BISCUIT'!
'Darkiplier'! Help Jack!
What are you doing?
AHH!
DON'T GET ME!
NO!
NOOO!
Oh, god no!
God, they were all over me!
This is gonna pay off eventually,
I'm gonna make it to the top of the leaderboard.
You're MINE!
AFK is my win!
*Laughs* 'I'm a Bot BITCH!'
'I'm a Bot BITCH'
There's so many bots!
Why are there bots?
Why would anyone bot this game?
Oh, god! Why?
Eheheheheheheheheh...
Come to the Jack!
[Crazed laughter]
Can I just-
Yep! I'll do that!
I'll take some of that!
I'll get that action.
Oooh, this is good.
Ahh, dis good.
Ahh dis good!
AH DIS GOOD!
AHAHA DIS GOOD!
Yes!
YES!
Come to me!
Yeah you know, you all know what's going on.
All these new player-
Oh my god!
So many new players!
Ohoho man!
Yes!
Yeees!
Uh-oh.
Going the other way now.
Going the other way.
Running away!
Running away very fastly!
Ohhhh, hello!
That ain't good.
Could be good!
Probably.
[Laughter]
Now we got it!
Now we're going for somethin'!
Don't know what, but we're going for somethin'.
Ooooh god, so scary!
Aw so scary!
Ohhh god, NO!
Don't give to him!
Aww no!
Dammit!
Was doing so gooood.
'PENISPLIER', no!
'PENISPLIER'!
Go away!
[Yells of terror, then laughter]
Oh, goddammit!
It's so scary!
It's so scary! [x2]
It's so scary! [x3]
Ueugh!
Oh, 'Mark is a suck' is a nice person!
I like 'Mark is a suck'!
Maybe he just didn't know who the hell I was.
I just got distracted by everything.
Now, this is- Uh-oh.
'LITTLE BISCUIT'! No!
NO! 'LITTLE BISCUIT!' NO!
Oh, don't do it!
Don't do it!
Oh, god. This is scary.
This is bad.
Ohh no.
'LITTLE BISCUIT'!
Eegh!
Eehh, I love you!
I love you! *muacks*
I love my little biscuit!
I love you!
[Loving moans (of terror)]
*muack*
There we go! That's my little biscuit!
*muacks*
'Hunting4Irish'...
Thank you, 'LITTLE BISCUIT'!
Don't consume me, though.
'Cause I still don't trust you!
Ohh man.
Oh man.
It, it pays to be t-
Whoah, hello.
Okay then.
I'll just collect my due and then...
get out of here.
'LITTLE BISCUIT'?
'LIL-LITTLE BISCUIT'?
'LIL-LITTLE BISCUIT?'
Ohh, 'LITTLE BISCUIT' you're the best!
Ohoho, you're so good!
Careful, 'LITTLE BISCUIT'.
Are you- are y-
Oh!
Oh okay!
Y-you did that!
Thank you!
'Boss Lady ♥'...
Aw, thank you 'Pepper'!
You're all so nice to me!
Aww...
I mean, I'm gonna eventually betray you and stab you all in the back,
but that's besides the point. Don't worry about it.
Oh yes.
Yesss.
Yesss!
Feed me!
Hey, you let off 'Little Boy Mark'!
Eeh, 'Tiny Boy- Mini Boy Mark'.
'Mini Boy Mark' is mah bud.
I'm not even on the leaderboard and I've got 4500 mass.
This is-
This is, b-bonkers.
This is absu- Oh, god, why?
Oh god! How did this happen?
How did this happen?
Oh god! What happened?
Oh, what is happening?
How is this possible?
Oh, man!
Oh, wow I'm so slow!
No!
Ahh!
Oh, don't do it!
Eugh don't do it!
I'm gonna pop anyway.
So, why not go over this?
Ahhh shit!
Ah shit dude!
Let's see if I can split-
Split this bitch...
If I can just-
thread the needle here!
Not even on the-
Oh! I just popped up on the list!
Whoaaa boy!
Whoaaaa boy! Aw fuck!
[Laughs]
Man, there are people that take this game way too seriously!
Even with the combined effort of everyone involved,
holyyyy shiiit~
Man, that's 'max'. He's #3.
At THAT size, he's #3.
Oh, my god!
I'm gonna give it all to 'BooperDooper'!
Give it all to 'BooperDooper'!
Give it to Booper!
Oh, fuck.
Fucked everyone over there.
No one wanted that one.
Okay! So this was Agar.io, I had a ton of fun.
Thank you everybody so much for joining me,
but when we flooded the server...
There's just too many heroes. We can't handle it all.
But thank you everybody so much for joining me,
if you wanna play another game with me in the future,
and a lot of you DID play a game with me, you just didn't realise it.
But if you wanna play a game with me in the future,
I'll tweet out another party, another day in another time.
So, thank you again everybody!
Check out the other Agar.io videos that I've done in the description.
And as always,
I will see YOU
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]